estos migrantes transitaron miles de
kilómetros a través de fronteras trochas
y selvas cuando creían Ver el final La
pesadilla comenzó de nuevo no se dirigen
a nosotros de
ellos En ningún momento nos dijeron que
ustedes van a ser deportado nada
solamente nos sacaron y Nos llevaron
allá el llanto dio paso a la
incertidumbre después de pisar suelo
estadounidense estos venezolanos fueron
deportados a Tijuana México dando inicio
al programa del gobierno estadounidense
pactado con las autoridades mexicanas
para frenar el creciente flujo
migratorio que llega por tierra
a todas las autoridades a que por favor
que vean este caso no sabemos qué hacer
estamos en el Limbo Estados Unidos no
nos da una solución y México tampoco la
ruta que puede durar meses inicia en
Venezuela la mayoría cruzan el peligroso
tapón del Darién fronteras selvática
entre Colombia y Panamá si lo logran al
periplo continúa por todo Centroamérica
hasta el norte de México donde las
mafias les ayudan a cruzar a Estados
Unidos Washington señaló que ofrecerá
estatus legal a 24.000 venezolanos
siempre y cuando estos lleven por vía
aérea y cuenten con un patrocinante
marginando así a los migrantes más
vulnerables porque estamos viviendo una
locura aquí todo no sabemos qué hacer
Tenemos es hambre hermano en México aquí
en la frontera ahí sabes ahí está puesta
al muro No hayamos que hacer estamos
jodidos no sabemos nos sacaron sin sin
decir mira está deportado si no fueran
deportados que me manden para Venezuela
un avión yo tuviera tranquilo en
Venezuela ya que me mande para Venezuela
pero Nos soltaron aquí en la frontera
qué hacemos ante muchos están llamando a
familiares y amigos que siguen en la
ruta hacia el norte para que paren su
tránsito y es que en lo que va de año
las autoridades fronterizas
contabilizaron más de 155.000 migrantes
venezolanos el triple que el año
anterior